Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: Dr. Bright is not
allowed to edit the list of things he is not
allowed to do!
Due to some unsubstantiated rumors perpetuated
by Dr. Bright himself, we must issue a formal
correction.
If an SCP file says never to do something,
that is not because we are trying to control
your mind.
For example, warnings not to look at SCP-096’s
face are for your own protection.
If you would like to look at its face and
bring about your own untimely end, then that
is up to you, but don’t say we didn’t
warn you.
AHEM!
No, we are not.
Dr. Bright, I see you.
You can’t type into this script any more,
your IP address has already been blocked!
In conclusion, if he would let us get our
work done for once in his miserable endless
life, Dr. Bright is not allowed to attempt
any manipulation, mind control, or subterfuge
of any kind via official SCP Foundation documents.